[Music]
as the country pauses to honor the
legacy of dr martin luther king jr there
you see his memorial in washington d.c
the first black woman to run the justice
department's civil rights division says
that voting discrimination persists
today
assistant attorney general kirsten clark
is her name talked with our jeff begayes
in her first tv interview since taking
office last year she says that
continuing dr king's quest for equal
access to the ballot box is one of her
department's top priorities
what do you think is the state of civil
rights in this country right now
we have made a lot of progress as a
nation but we've still got a long way to
go
assistant attorney general kristin clark
here's the frustration of many over new
state voting restrictions and says her
department is using every tool at its
disposal to protect voting rights would
you say that it's people of color who
are being targeted by these laws
yes
voting discrimination
is alive and well well who do you think
is behind this effort
well look i do not view this as a
partisan issue you don't i don't i was
there at the white house when president
bush
signed uh the last reauthorization of
the bill into law
it passed in congress in 2006 by a 98-0
vote in the senate you might be the only
one in this town that doesn't see it as
a partisan issue
well i'm hopeful i'm hopeful that we can
get back to that place where we've been
time and time again where congress has
worked in bipartisan fashion to
renew the voting rights act
right now the legislation is stalled in
congress the biden administration and
senate democrats do not have the votes
to pass their election reform measures
within the democratic party there is
growing frustration that the justice
department and the president fail to
reverse republican efforts to change
state election laws with the midterm
election approaching
and control of congress on the ballot
you feel any pressure to get this done
there's an urgency
for sure i understand
the frustration that people feel
as we watch states that are working to
make it harder for people to vote
clark has a reputation for not backing
down from a fight she was raised in
working class east new york brooklyn one
of new york city's toughest
neighborhoods
he says her parents who immigrated to
the u.s from jamaica wanted their kids
to get a good education
as a teenager clark attended cho
rosemary hall in connecticut one of the
most prestigious boarding schools in the
country alumni include president john f
kennedy how did you adapt you know i
just settled right in it was very it was
not easy at that time no not easy a very
different environment than east new york
during her third year at choate she says
she learned how the law
could be a powerful tool for change when
she sat in on a landmark desegregation
case focusing on the disparities between
urban and suburban schools
in many ways cho
has a lot to do with my journey to where
i am today today she is the first black
woman heading the civil rights division
headquartered in former fbi director j
edgar hoover's old office
from her desk she can see pennsylvania
avenue and capitol hill
but she hasn't forgotten how she got
here
i know what it's like
for families who grow up poor and who
struggle
who live paycheck to paycheck i i know
what that experience is like i know what
it's like to
be marginalized sidelined and silenced
and that personal perspective shapes who
i am
for cbs morning's jeff begays washington
i knew very little about her but it's
really interesting to hear a story i
like when jeff asked her about going to
cho which is a predominantly uh white
school in wallingford connecticut she
said i just settled right in she said i
didn't say it was easy but i just
settled right in look where she sits
today in the view from her window she
also said voting restrictions were not
political not a political issue in her
view it might not have started out
political tony but it sure feels very
political yeah